this year has been like
1918 meets 1928 29 meets 1968.
so you've had a great pandemic you've
had economic
unrest um and you've had the untethering
of a country along the lines of race
uh similar to 68. but we've had all of
those moments in one year
for me personally i was i was already in
this really raw space
you know i was rocked by a modern artery
and brianna taylor and i'm trying to
figure out
what do you do right like like what do
we do
and i think a lot of people are asking
that that same question and then
george floyd is murdered and all of a
sudden
like the world awakens watching my
daughter
um go out and protest in the streets you
know my daughter is 15 years old
she'll be 16 soon and it was such a
conflicting moment it was a moment of
tension for me because i was so excited
that she had to wear with all in the
warrant to go out
with her mask on and have a sign that
said that her life matters
and then on the flip side i was so
heartbroken and sad
that my daughter couldn't be like barron
trump um you know
she has to be 15 and go out and wear a
sign reaffirming her human
dignity her humanity sometimes people
give their life you know they want to
give their life for a cause
and while george floyd's murder caused
caused a revolution
he didn't give his life his life was
taken from him
when you have time to sit and digest
things they have a bigger effect on you
and so as we're sitting and we're
watching the news
and we're like i'm sitting here thinking
there's no way that there's a man being
killed
on national television like this is a
murder i think that we sometimes get
confused and i want people to fully
understand this
george floyd his case the case of
derrick chauvin
was not justice it was accountability
colin kaepernick just simply knelt
down to acknowledge the reality
of a police killing of unarmed black men
and the response to him
and the vilification and the isolation
and the rejection
and now just two years later look where
we are
think about how more than an athlete
became a thing someone told lebron just
to
shut up and dribble who is anybody to
tell these athletes that they can't
speak
up on these social issues it's coming
from their heart it's coming naturally
wnba players and some of the the women's
national team
soccer players and athletes from all
sports
speaking up uh and making a difference
it's important
i was so happy that there were
conversations around whether or not they
should
sit out the nba should sit out in the
aftermath of george floyd and
when they did after jacob lake what i
would like to see happen from the league
and with the players is that they also
understand the importance of the
economics of this challenge
think about it think about how many jobs
all of us hired a diversity and
inclusion officer
all of us hired somebody to deal with
these issues in big companies small
companies
organizations everywhere lots of ceos
lots of people came out
and they talked about it and said they
were going to do so many things
i think as we go on um in life
we have to keep giving opportunity i've
seen a lot of lip service
i've heard a lot of people commit to
doing the right thing
and there was an article that came out
saying that very few
companies that made funding commitments
around george floyd's murder
very few of them have acted upon those
things
some of it was performative some of it
was uh
you know justice for you know the sake
of social media
um and you know you know giving somebody
fifty thousand dollars no we'll take
the money but giving somebody fifty
thousand dollars but not changing your
corporate culture is
is not what we're talking about so i
hope that a lot of these corporations
are doing the work from within
their building that's first um you know
not just having the illusion of
inclusion but promoting diverse
voices around them i have seen
significant change in
large companies and corporations you
know making sure that they allocate
appropriate
amounts of funding and various other
things but i've also seen
internally how they have had discussions
on how to create a significant change
and an effective change whether it be in
their hiring practices
whether it be in understanding what the
systemic issues have been
the unfortunate truth is that we don't
tend to learn from our wins
we learn from our losses and it is so
sad that it took george floyd's life
in that video to change
uh hearts and minds and it's
even more sad that it hasn't changed
some hearts and minds
what i think 2020 did was give us
clear vision into all of the many
challenges the country faces
um i think that 2021 invites us
to remember to see clearly even on the
other side of a tragedy knowing full
well that those tragedies still exist
what i've taken from this this really
difficult
hard year has truly been
inspirational and sad the sad part is
the deaths
that we've experienced because of the
pandemic the racial unrest
that we've experienced historically
the inspirational part is there
is a generation and a willingness to say
hey we're going to get better we're
going to fix it
over the last year i think um the
lessons learned are
that no matter what something is going
to happen
whether planes crashing in the building
greatrecessions.com bubble crashes or
a coronavirus and you have to be
prepared and how do you get prepared for
the unknown is by constantly educating
yourself and constantly trying to pivot
and surrounding yourself with
like-minded people who are also
educating themselves
you see these this next generation
rising up and
they're not jaded and they're not hard
yet they're still hopeful but they're
looking at this country and they're
saying
this is what i'm inheriting and i don't
want this
i want better i'm choosing better i'm
choosing more
and so i think you know that what's been
hopeful is like it's like okay what have
i learned
how can how can we help empower this
generation
to be what we need them to be i think we
need to go back
you know to that um the first time we
were born and we have a pure heart
um and we take everybody
um into our heart into our space you
know with
a blank slate we remember him every day
not just
today in a one year remembrance
we've made a great deal of progress in
this country no one if anyone tells you
that we haven't they're lying and
nothing about this country is
irredeemable
but we must deconstruct a lot of the
systems of oppression that we have
and reimagine what they look like and so
that's my goal
to reimagine what this country should be